dm
hallo mein name ist luca und ich mag
erdbeeren
leider gibt sie gerade nicht nur im
supermarkt ich weiß nicht warum aber ich
hab grad echt lust auf erdbeeren
darum geht's nicht ich habe schon mal
ein video hochgeladen wo ich euch
youtube videos gezeigt hatte die null
aufrufe haben das video was wir uns als
erst angezeigt wird ist gedacht luca das
video schon fast ein jahr alt mache ich
das doch einfach nochmal deswegen bin
ich wieder auf der website youtube und
wird was ist das denn
das ist das erste video klasse das war's
dieses video existiert nicht das video
fängt gut an bei uns hier
warum laden leute sowas hoch er zeigt
wir irgendwas auspackt fällt also eine
goldene karte drin jetzt macht er das
wieder aufnimmt es wegschaut in das
päckchen das ist nämlich auch um das
war's mit sprays das juckt mich ein
volvo nicht dumm ich traurig eigentlich
vor allem wie schlecht ist diese
aufnahme von dem auto alter wie kannst
du bitte noch mehr wackeln und noch mehr
unschärfe reinpacken so dass ich
vielleicht gar nicht mehr vom auto
erkennen kann auf war
ich habe total vergessen dass ich das
nicht mehr hochgeladen habe dieses von
petit weil danach wochenlang meine
ganzen empfohlene videos leisten uhr mit
seinem schwach sinnvoll war
diesmal erst nachdem luca kommen wir
jetzt aber auch schon zum nächsten video
und zwar existiert nicht grand theft
auto 5 a match okay das ist der der
titel von dem video er versucht denke
ich da hinten eine person abzuschießen
ob er das hinkriegt ist eine andere
sache er guckt um den kiosk rum
nur wenige minuten später
dm
jetzt läuft er weiter von der yacht auf
die obere plattform der yacht um die
jetzt läuft er noch weiter hoch jetzt
läuft er in die acht rein in einen raum
und das du kannst dich durch gebäude
schießen ihr make it kommt man also ja
drehst vielleicht auf den korb traf das
jetzt mal in die richtige positiv aus
der breko rico video that solche spiele
sind doch das langweiligste der welt
oder
auch komme wahrscheinlich existiert das
video nicht oder bibelkreis wer einfach
wenn jetzt ein video von irgendeinem
übels bekannten youtuber kämen würde was
einfach gerade erst hochgeladen wurde
und dementsprechend noch mal aufrufe
hätte stattdessen kriege ich solche
videos wunderschönes haus tolle nachbarn
sieht man hier gemütlicher
eingangsbereich gemütliches wohnzimmer
ein gemütliches arbeitszimmer wundervoll
alles sauber auch hier sehen wir auch
super bodenplatte die tür auch sehr
schön bin ich aus versehen auf einem
immobilien sender gelandet oder das ist
wohl eine werbung für ein buch und zwar
freezers daniel allyn mal schauen um was
es in diesem buch geht
korrekt jetzt weiß ich warum es in dem
buch geht um existieren diese videos
hier erklärt uns jemand wieder 350
dollar am tag verdient nämlich mit
eigener website und noch einer anderen
website positivtrend bei fest ok und
dann macht er das hier und dann zeigt er
uns wäre das halt die fresse
dieser clip heißt epic schott und er
schiebt er hat das schlechteste aim des
jahres was ist das für ein video money
bin noch nicht 18 ich darf das
eigentlich gar nicht gucken der
bildschirm ist noch schwarz jetzt habe
ich ein kleines kind was malt läuft zu
der mutter hin die mutter holt etwas ok
werbung für magie wir machen weiter der
titel ist movie 1806 und da steht jemand
oben drauf ist es glaube ich so eine art
siegerehrung warum sind die alle plätze
auf einer höhe ist der erste nicht sonst
irgendwie höher
die preview place das schild stellt
wieder hinkommen die nächsten hoch
wahrscheinlich jetzt hier auf einmal
auch erste oder vor allem standen
einfach bei der ersten siegerehrung nur
zwei leute oben der dritte vierte und
fünfte platz war überhaupt nicht
vorhanden das heißt einem wettbewerb um
insgesamt zwei leute teilgenommen
richtig richtig gut
ich verstehe eishockey nicht das
natürlich ärgerlich
diese frei vorm tor schiesst daneben wie
süßen baby was ihre milch trinkt das ist
das ist hammer in ich ein kind hätte
würde ich das nie ins internet stellen
du weißt ja nicht ob das das kind will
das schon wieder so ein video mit seinem
richtig kreativen titel und zwar movie 4
304 wie ein hund an etwas zieht
wahrscheinlich einen pappkarton jung was
mache ich mit meinem leben hat mir
gerade geschrieben was heute bei mir
geht und noch etwas machen wollen glaube
ich würde es gern was mit dir machen
aber ich muss mir gerade videos
anschauen ihn nicht existiert dieses
video sehen wir verfügen aber dass mit
diesem video verknüpfte youtube konto
gekündigt wurde alles klar wieso wird es
mir dann hier angezeigt
ich dachte fällt runter kannst du mal
fallen
das war überhaupt nicht witzig hier
haben wir jemanden der mit seinem
nintendo rumspielt in folge fließt wales
so gut wahrscheinlich gut oder bei
diesem video haben wir auf jeden fall
schonmal krasses intro nämlich prime
mordio playground judith transition
vielleicht lerne er heute euro
das machst du super viel zu hören auf
einer am boden liegt oder wie ich zeige
euch jetzt mal wie viele videos hier
wirklich privat sind also dieses video
ist privat dieses video existiert nicht
dann haben wir hier das ist auch es
existiert ich verstehe kein wort ich bin
dumm ich bin doch ich bin ich bin ich
bin dumm weil ihr die ganze kanton hatte
bei den videoeinblendungen ich war auf
dieser website und hab mich halt dabei
aufgenommen wie ich auf diese videos mit
0 aufruf reagiert habe also ihr habt ja
gerade das video gesehen deswegen ist
ihr das ja allerdings habe ich bei
meinem aufnahmeprogramm vom bildschirm
den ton nicht angemacht ich blöd gewesen
deswegen musste ich halt leider voll
viele videoausschnitte rausschneiden
weil die musik gemacht hätten wenn ihr
auch den ton gehört hätte beispielsweise
am ende wird noch etwas von dem
franzosen eingefügt der so wörter
erklärt hat oder bei dem eishockey video
beispielsweise sind zwischendurch die
leute richtig krass ab gegangen und da
habe ich mich dann nur so gefragt sei
warum warum geht ihr jetzt überhaupt ab
aber ich habe leider den ton ich
aufgenommen
deswegen konnte ich das leider nicht
mehr mit reinpacken ins video wohl das
mega cool gewesen wer also das tut mir
leid wenn jetzt ein paar sachen
vielleicht allgemein gar keinen sinn
gemacht haben wie ich darauf reagiert
habe weil ihr den tonart nicht gehört
habe ich während der aufnahme allerdings
schon hart genug hafen kommen jetzt auch
ganz kurze zeit in sachen
eben kurz sagen wollte und zwar habe ich
mein premiere pro neu gemacht und ich
schneide mit den dm premiere pro und ich
habe das problem dass wenn ich meine
tonspur irgendwie aus ganz vielen
kleinen sachen zusammen als
verschachtelte sequenz machen möchte
werden wir den audiospuren nicht alles
angezeigt sondern so zwischenzeitlich
alles so ruhig und dann wieder ein
bisschen was angezeigt müssen antworten
zu sagen wenn ich sehr viele audio clips
zusammenpackte zu einem verschachtelt
dann zeigt er jetzt zwar an ok hat voll
oft kein audio aber man hört es trotzdem
man sieht die spuren mit den wellen nur
leider nicht vielleicht kennt sich ja
irgendwer von euch mit adobe premiere
pro aus falls dies der fall sein sollte
schreibt michael man die kommentare wie
ich das vielleicht beheben kann und
jetzt sagt luca glaube ich noch ganz
kurz das alles keinen sinn ergeben hat
und dann macht die renn karts irgendwie
macht das glaube ich alles keinen sinn
heute also den titel dieses videos habe
ich auf jeden fall umgesetzt ich habe
mir youtube videos angesehen die alle
keine aufrufe haben das heißt wenn ihr
das auch machen wollt könnt ihr auf die
website youtube gehen und da kann man
sich dann videos angucken
beziehungsweise krieg die vorgeschlagen
die null aufrufe haben allerdings waren
die videos teilweise wirklich ein
bisschen komisch
wahrscheinlich haben sie deswegen
einfach nur aufrufe wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich über einen
live freuen last auf jeden fall mal ein
leichter wenn ihr denkt dass euch das
video gelegt hat um das den leykauf da
lassen können wenn es euch wie ihr euch
gefallen hat dass jetzt leiten könnte
schreibt mal in die kommentare 0
wenn ihr gerade noch dran sein um das
video wirklich bis zum ende geschaut
habt ihr seht hier vorne uns mal die
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren dann seid ihr
quasi neue abonnent von meinem kanal
wäre mégane eis weil es auch nichts
kostet und hier findet ihr ein video
eingeblendet wo max und ich ein riesiges
pizzastück gemacht haben war sehr lecker
pizzas leider angebrannt aber video war
lustig guckt euch an
ja